I'm Sean Duffy and Flora Ingram and this
is a special edition of the Ingram angle
from New York City all right we have a
big show for you tonight so let's Jump
Right In
the bite administration's word of the
year is shortage
we talk about a teacher shortage we saw
the impact of the chip shortage a
housing shortage in U.S we had a
shortage of shipping Supply shortage of
trucking shortage what haven't we had a
shortage of this year everyone remembers
what happened with baby formula back in
the spring when mothers were stuck
driving hours just to get one bottle to
feed their newborns be a problem to be
able to feed your baby but now it's
really scary it has been a nightmare
every few days hunting for baby formula
how haven't we learned from this those
same mothers may still be struggling if
they have older kids because now we're
seeing a disturbing shortage of
antibiotics in Children's Tylenol then
of course there's a labor shortage which
is impacting everything from Oregon
snowplow drivers to Orlando restaurant
workers even 9-1-1 calls there aren't
enough EMS workers to go around and
that's leading to a lag in response time
which in some situations could mean life
or death your safety is at stake the
incremental has well documented the
ongoing police Staffing shortages and
now we're learning about a lack of
public defenders listen to what's
happening in Oregon because of it
crimes involving both misdemeanors and
felonies are being dismissed and those
include crimes such as property crimes
crimes with Firearms low-level assaults
and even cases of domestic violence
we cannot continue like this did you
know there's even a diesel fuel shortage
one major supplier called this a code
red diesel is what's used to power
trucks and buses trains construction and
Manufacturing equipment it's even used
to heat homes
so if the winter get really harsh I
don't know how we're gonna do it and I'm
thinking of getting another going back
to my other part-time job which I had
before covid and so I'll have two
part-time jobs in order to just survive
that's what it's really about for so
many right now survival
Biden promised us a better America when
are we gonna see that hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else